oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans sion par
les sports le rendez vous qu'il ne faut
absolument pas manquer si vous êtes un
amoureux du sport local pour
m'accompagner aujourd'hui de véritables
stars à elles ne sont pas sur la
croisette à cannes mais avec nous sur ce
plateau présentation en musique s'il
vous plaît on commence à ma droite on la
compare souvent à la sublime monica
bellucci aussi piquante que l'actrice
elle est aussi à l'aise devant les
caméras que sur une barre de pole dance
son sport de prédilection notre
ambassadrice de charme et l'aide de la
grange est avec nous
bonjour et la valeur de vente à la vue
est très bien mais je suis ravie la
petite comparaison avec monica bellucci
je sais pas si elle est très très très
judicieuse mais moi je prends tu
problème oui mais voilà je prends tous
les compliments ça fait rêver
on passe de l'autre côté musique on le
compare souvent cette émission à
l'acteur russell crowe avec sa barbe et
son caractère de leader comme lui ils
adorent l'histoire et les gags yater
pierre chevalier du rugby-club de
versailles est avec nous pendant une
heure ça lui quelle forme et bonheur
l'ancien minot aller au sol quand
j'aurai nîmes
j'aurais mieux pour ce plugin si j'avais
su pour que notre bien marquer le coup
mais toujours toujours heureux d'être là
sous les sunlights et en heureux de vous
avoir sur ce plateau on passe de l'autre
côté à musique quand on le voit dans la
rue les gens le confondent souvent avec
la légende américaine bruce willis c'est
un chroniqueur d'exception il a un
sixième sens c'est bac font l'effet d'un
armageddon vous ne passerez pas une
journée en enfer avec lui le cinquième
élément
genlis ex-entraîneur de plaisir est avec
nous boon sort genre comment allez vous
toujours impeccable
alors cette rumeur sur bruce willis
c'est vrai ou pas ah non non non non non
soyons honnêtes
par contre monica bellucci je prends mon
tribut vous avez pas les cheveux par
l'échauffement on passe de l'autre côté
musique c'est le antonio banderas de
plaisir comme le célèbre acteur vous
pouvez le voir chevauchée de temps en
tension cheval noir dans
civile fait plus qu on le surnomme
depuis ses débuts dans cette émission le
zorro yves binois raul côté l'autre et
est avec nous pendant une heure bonjour
à vous comment allez vous tu perds et
vous très bien alors on peut vous voir
chevauchée dans les yvelines
oui la nuit masqué sur toi le jour le
jour je me tiens tranquille et le soir
je vous rend justice en justice alors
passer au poids de l'émission va parler
de football les moins de 15 ans des noms
courts ont remporté la finale de
l'orangé football challenge face au
racing club de france ce samedi 18 mai
la rencontre s'est déroulée au parc des
princes à la mi temps du match entre
paris et dijon le principe les joueurs
devaient marquer dans un face à face
avec le gardien
en partant du milieu de terrain ils ont
ensuite assisté au match de ligue 1 et à
la remise des trophées de champion de
france du psg
ce trophée signifie t'il quelque chose
oui ou non voter oui non c'est une
compétition amicale en jeu je le
rappelle c'est de partager gens pourquoi
j'ai pas trop compris l'intérêt donc je
peux partager
donc les jeunes partent du milieu de
terrain russe un pompier indien dans un
face à face et marc oursin judas est
l'équipe qui marque le plus de buts a
gagné oui c'est pour comme l'est la
mi-temps goisset swiss est sympa c'est
ses orangers salon du genre comme un
copain qui me fait ça qui remettait le
trophée donc oui bon pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas ce sont des jeunes avec on
va les encourager
je vois pas trop et oui l es tu pour
vous aussi vous étiez partager vers moi
je donne toujours du crédit à ce genre
ce genre de démarche parce qu'elles sont
elles sont saines et elles vont dans le
bon sens après est ce que c'est une
signification sportive est ce qu'il ya
une prouesse à honorer j'en suis moins
sûr donc c'est pour ça que j'étais
mitigé pierre pour deux raisons je pense
que le il ya le terme challenge dedans
et c'est pas une une coupe - championnat
ça se déroule à la mi temps puis de
deuxième raison ça se ça permet à des
jeunes des jeunes footballeurs de foule
est là
la pelouse du parc des princes d'aller
d'aller mettre une toile dans les buts
du parc des princes coup c'est à la fois
ludique et spectaculaire
sportivement c'est peut-être parce qu'il
ya de plus de plus enthousiasmant de
marquer des penaltys comme ça du bord du
terrain du milieu du terrain mais c'est
un bel événement à la mi temps d'un
match de liga ils vont s'en souvenir
toute leur vie à hélène va je pense que
de toute façon mais le parc des princes
on s'en souvient quand on y va on s'en
souvient donc oui mon se souvenir après
voilà c'était pas un match c'était voilà
des petites rencontres
mais oui oui je pense que ça s'est
toujours à soutenir oui voilà agréable à
avoir vécu ça peut les motiver
éventuellement pierre à aller un peu
plus loin dans dans le football
ce d'ailleurs pourquoi pas un jour
fouler cette pelouse mais en tant que
professionnel là je pense qu'ils sont
vos contacts avec les pros puisqu'ils
ont assisté après à la remise du trophée
de la ligue 1 donc oui au minimum ça
goûte et a sauvé à ce type à ce type de
lieux d'événements
le parc était sûrement pas plaint à 7 à
ce moment de la saison mais mais oui
être au contact des pros événements dans
les tribunaux à 45 personnes a quand
même on aurait donc donc encore plus sa
raison de plus certains habitants donc
certains spectateurs sont allés à la
buvette fortement alors toute victoire
avec modération toujours mais c'est donc
on côtoie les pros leur lieu de travail
un lieu absolument mythique quel parc
des princes les vestiaires le
le terrain donc oui oui ça leur fait
goûter au haut niveau dans une dans une
ambiance presque détendu je pense qu'ils
ont quand même un peu la pression donc
oui ça peut leur donner envie d'aller
plus loin
genre vous êtes d'accord avec lui mais
je pense déjà que ce sont des petits
jeunes dans les clubs donc des espaces
déjà qui rêve
il rêvait plus loin une reprise entre 13
et 15 ans voilà wilson 1 et club ne
s'est pas déplacé quel délai voilà c'est
ça voilà ils sont dans le club donc
c'est comme tout rêve de sportif
d'athènes dans le sommet d'être un jour
professionnel c'est tout bon on leur
souhaite en tout cas et nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de football et l'équipe de
trappes pourrait monter en régionale 2
font également un coup de projecteur sur
le rugby club de versailles qui a perdu
son premier match de la saison
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler de basket dans ce talk du
basket pour débuter cette page résultats
l'entente le chesnay versailles 78 peut
jubiler le fcv 70 a réussi à éviter une
remonta d'assaut samedi 10 juillet sur
son terrain en quarts de finale de
prénationale vainqueur 73 à 52 à l'aller
face à paris 14 les hommes de la cité
royale se sont imposés au retour 81 à 71
sur leur parquet on écoute les réactions
il fallait être concentré à respecter
les consignes et jouer au basket
voilà tous les matches et il faut gagner
non même si on était à plus 20 ans
ou qui se rendent dans des
j'écris c'était de gagner l'objectif
c'était véritablement de jouer pour
gagner et surtout pas de jouer pour nous
pour ne pas perdre et c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait du coup ça a fait un match
plein voilà ils se sont défendus avec
leurs armes et on a encore été plus fort
ce soir donc c'est amplement mérité je
pense raul une belle victoire
oui malgré tout partir du moment où il
s'agit d'une victoire c'est beau on peut
pas attendre des grands écarts à chaque
fois au niveau du score
j'aime assez ce qui a été dit au niveau
du duduk a dû jouer pour ne pas perdre
mais plutôt jouer pour gagner
si une dynamique que je salue donc bravo
la question sur ce thème c'est la
victoire du coach ou des joueurs
d'éviter une remonte à da comme celle-là
rouge pour le coach et verte pour les
joueurs vers pour les joueurs vous êtes
partagés décidément genre pourquoi
ouais je suis partagé parce que des
entraîneurs bon on a souvent tendance à
dire que quand ça gagne c'est grâce aux
joueurs et qu'elle s'appelle c'est la
faute de l'entraîneur
mais là on ne peut que c'est un groupe
sport collectif donc forcément c'est un
groupe c'est la victoire revient aussi
bien aux joueurs car l'entraîneur qui
surtout parce quelqu'un c'est assez
tactique surtout par rapport à cette
remonte à la passe qu'il fallait quand
même anticipé le cpa tic appliquées
relâchement sur le deuxième match tout à
fait donc cesser ces puces les joueurs
ou le coach mais je pense que c'est
surtout parce que j'insiste parce que ça
va très vite au basket et il ya beaucoup
de changements tactiques et c'est quand
même jusqu'à prendre du bon temps c'est
quand même l'entraîneur qui donne des
directives et qui me place les joueurs
et qui fait rentrer les joueurs par
rapport à leur qualité individuelle donc
je pense que l'on ne peut pas le mettre
à l'écart mais on ne peut pas non plus
le mettre en avant
donc pour moi c'est les deux c'est beau
ça j'étais mitigé parce que c'est pas
l'entraîneur où les joueurs c'est un
groupe c'est le tout et c'est la
mayonnaise a bien pris ce ces deux
matches avec elle tire un petit peu un
petit frayeur sur le deuxième le
résultat compte
seul le résultat compte raul vous aussi
vous étiez meat is est pas une tige et
nous allons rentrer dans un débat qui
peut qui peut parfois vraiment parasiter
les performances quand il s'agit de
donner du crédit à un fondamental ou à
un autre soit le joueur soit
l'entraîneur
je pense que là la perte sauf cas
exceptionnels la performance de toujours
être connu à 100% des deux côtés et
qu'il n'y a pas un élément qui pourrait
nous nous nous comment nous attirer vers
une une manière de l'alizé d'analysé
d'un côté ou d'un autre et donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai pas voulu répondre oui
ou non parce que ce n'est pas un oui ou
non c'est toujours sait pas toujours
mais en tous les cas pourquoi pourquoi
la ici vouloir reconnaître que c'est
plus grâce à aux joueurs que
l'entraîneur c'est vraiment un boulot
d'équipé encore plus dans un sport
collectif
hélène quand vous utile pour les joueurs
oui moi je pars aussi du principe que on
a beau avoir un bon coach et des joueurs
derrière on part
un minimum de comment dire de pratiquer
deux
voilà deux d'expérience voilà deux
niveaux et c'est évidemment que ça
mènera pas du tout à la victoire
maintenant en effet comme disait jean
c'est vraiment les les changements
d'équipé les positionnements de d'un tel
à tel moment les modifications de la
demande dans l'équipe et sur un terrain
qu'il faut que la stratégie a fonctionné
ou pas donc c'est par rapport à d'autres
sports
c'est vrai que le coach a quand même
comment dire primordial oui oui voilà
qu'hier je trouve que c'est un principe
qui est devenu à la mode la remontée de
la mémé que en foot pour l'instant c'est
que c'est là on a été confronté pendant
deux saisons de suite pour le paris
saint germain au football en ligue des
champions par des scénarios complètement
improbable de là à les transposer à
n'importe quel sport et notamment le
basket c'est vrai que faut il penser
dans un coin de la tête pour motiver les
joueurs mais ça peut arriver en tout cas
c'est ça pose sa b2 est revenu dans les
conversations d'avant match et comme dit
comme disait jean c'est hier c'est
encore plus rapide au basket avec des
paniers à deux et à trois points c'est
encore plus rapide de combler un écart
de 20 points
ceci étant dit pour répondre à la
question
c'est vraiment un travail d'équipé dans
tous les sports les entraîneurs
entraînent les joueurs jouent les
dirigeants dirigent mais là en
l'occurrence il faut d'abord fixer la
stratégie prévenir les joueurs avertir
des joueurs et c'est après c'est eux qui
sont sur le terrain et qui font qu'ils
font la maille qui vont et qui vous
chercher la victoire bamba qui sera
peut-être un futur habitués de votre
plateau avec avec nous sur cette
émission
précisez justement l'important c'était
de gagner c'est à dire pas se dire on a
de l'avancé on a de l'avancé on peut
voir venir il faut griller donc là en
l'occurrence c'est c'est la
responsabilité tactique du coach mais
après c'est là c'est la hargne l envie
des joueurs d'aller chercher un d'aller
chercher une victoire et puis là au
final ça fait quasiment une trentaine de
points d'écart sur l'ensemble des deux
matches justement bamba c'est 38 ans il
a joué un peu plus haut en national de
l'union nationale 2 en nationale 3 est
ce que finalement un jour comme celui là
a pu apporter son expérience dans ce
type de configuration c'est à dire ne
pas stresser ne pas se laisser déborder
par l'équipe adverse
forcément oui forcément en force et
l'expérience c'est d'ailleurs c'est à
dire c'est ce qui fait la wii largement
ce qu'il fait là dessus à la canaliser
un petit peu cette émotion ce qui fait
la différence dans des cas de figure
comme celui là un jour un joueur qui a
évolué à plus haut niveau
va savoir va savoir pas savoir calmer le
jeu va savoir remettre son équipe dans
l'avancée et pour empêcher justement
cette fameuse je pense que c'est même le
coach va s'appuyer sur des joueurs
d'expérience comme ça peu pour fixer
figer la stratégie et pendant le match
maintenir les maintenir de cinq sous
pression pour pouvoir pour justement
empêcher tout scénario improbable
c'est ce que je disais le rôle de
l'entraîneur il est primordial là est un
joueur comme comme mba on voit il est
sur le terrain
là c'est le moment où on a besoin de ces
joueurs là sur le parquet il n'est pas
sur le banc en train de souffler en
temps de se reposer il est humble et sur
le parquet parce que je pense qu'il a dû
faire énormément de temps de jeu sur ce
match aller à des moments ad -
certainement très stratégique
vous avez déjà connu ce type de match
jean dans le passé même si en rugby
c'est un peu plus compliqué parce qu'il
remontera vers c'est ce que j'ai eu tort
à bon ça existe aussi on l'a vu ce
week-end avec le stade toulousain poux
stade toulousain qui a fait une remontée
la magnifique il avait gagné près de 7 0
en deuxième mi-temps quoi donc
on le voit aussi redit on le voit
quasiment tous les sports pierre l'animé
ce que je disais au basket parce que ça
va très très vite au basket on voit que
le match il n'y a pas un sport collectif
où le match il n'est pas finie au coup
de sifflet parce que là ça va vraiment
très très très vite on voit qu'en
quelques secondes
le score peut basculer c'est sûr qu'il y
avait un point d'avancé ça bascule pas
mais ça va le score évolue très vite
donc d'où l'importance d'un bon d'un bon
groupe
entraîneurs et joueurs alors avec ce
résultat l'entente le chesnay versailles
78 se qualifie pour le final four de la
division l'équipe affrontera meudon en
demi finale sur terrain neutre à
palaiseau pour une revanche le 1er juin
les me donner les avait battus au mois
de février dernier en cas de victoire
les joueurs de la cité royale se verrait
propulsé en nationale 3 en écoute le
coach est là n'est acquis à part une
place en demi finale
tout reste à faire et on va jouer notre
saison maintenant non plus sur x match
là et leur expliquent deux donc or on le
sait et il va falloir faire le job
bien évidemment ce groupe a le niveau
parce que je sais qu'on aura du coeur
et on leur montrera raul ils peuvent le
faire j'en suis j'en suis persuadé
contre meudon ah oui oui j'en suis
persuadé ainsi une équipe qui finalement
un petit peu même niveau que paris 14
ils ont terminé premiers de leur poule
paris 14 avait également terminé premier
de sa poule en fin de la poule de
l'entente tauch universal qui était
deuxième
donc on a à peu près serré parce que
juste une petite question est ce que le
vainqueur du match me dont contre
versailles par le oui est ce que le
vainqueur menton alors me dont on est
sûr de monter donc si versailles va me
dont en demi finale versailles est sûr
de monter au jeu demain et ça parce que
la motivation ne sera pas la même
donc au lieu de monter dans les
discussions que la motivation est donc
c'est pas un match couperet pour les
deux équipes c'est pas mal augmenté on
va dire pour les deux équipes meudon et
déjà sur le monte et on va vous dire ce
qu'on veut faire ça il est obligé de
gagner pour pour remonter sauf que elle
va jouer contre une équipe qui les
joueurs sont déjà un aspect c'est pour
ça que je suis champion des champions
oui oui mais oui mais là je suis
d'accord sauf que l'enjeu n'est pas le
même
elle a géré par l'oniam 1 et la
motivation ne sera pas le même non plus
à votre avis comment il faut aborder ce
match
hélène avec la gagne la motivation
lagane la stratégie comme finalement ils
ont déjà fait et
et l' envie de surprendre vraiment et il
faut s'appuyer sur le dernier match
peut-être oui après toute façon sur
toutes les stratégies qui ont déjà
fonctionné
ils sont face à une équipe assez
assez grande emphase donc je pense
qu'ils vont être concentrés et qu'ils
peuvent y arriver on sera le mot de la
fin sur cette thématique on continue ce
talk part du rugby l'incroyable saison
de versailles est malheureusement
terminée les joueurs de la cité royale
invaincu cette année en 21 matchs ont
perdu face à un autre rcv le rugby-club
vesoul sur terrain neutre en 16e de
finale du championnat de france honneur
après s'être neutralisées sur le score
de 23 partout après prolongation les
verse ayant finalement craqué aux tirs
au but et ne verront pas les huitièmes
pierre chevalier
une réaction je précise que le la saison
n'est pas n'est pas terminée pour tous
les seniors du club léo qui préserve
l'équipe réserve continue ce qu'elle
s'est qualifié en battant le ce qui fait
que s'est qualifié pour les quarts de
finale c'est évidemment évidemment un
scénario complètement fou sur ce sur ce
match des seizièmes de finale contre le
vert c'est raul et sans déflorer la
suite quelques regrets à avoir
mais ça n'enlève en rien évidemment la
formidable saison qu'on règle
réaliser les seniors 1 avec la montée en
fédérale 3 avec on en parle elle a
démonté justement donc les saisons qui
compte lorsqu elles finissent par une
montée l'un titre de champion
ile-de-france comme le com l'équipe
réserve
et puis bon un petit et un petit trajet
en championnat de france avec uniquement
un tour de passer mais ça ça clôt manuel
malgré tout une fantastique saison comme
on en vient on revivra pas forcément de
sitôt ça arrive souvent qu'on se fasse
éliminer aux tirs au but face à ce but
oui ça c'est très très très très moyen
de toute ma carrière je n'ai jamais vécu
comme ça c'est sûr une finale en plus
donc c'est très rare parce que c'est
c'est égalité la fin du temps
réglementaire et égalité à la fin des
prolongations c'est très très rare et on
réduit même induire haut niveau je crois
que la dernière c'était agen béziers
donc 84 en seconde ça donc c'est un
montant non c'est très rare qu'on aille
jusqu'aux tirs au but au rugby la
question sur ce thème faut-il nourrir
des regrets après cette défaite
je parle bien sûr de la saison 1 un
petit duel entre raul et jean hohl à moi
je dis non parce que je suis je suis
contre qu'on enlève les mérite qu'on
avait déjà accordé à versailles dans des
émissions précédentes
compte tenu de leur magnifique saison
donc c'est pas au moment où finalement
le
le rêve s'arrête que il faut nourrir des
regrets à avoir des sentiments négatifs
face à tout ça c'est un beau rêve qui
prend fin comme tous les beaux rêves
voilà il vous voulez pas vous fâcher
avec qui arrive alors moi j'ai dit j'ai
dit oui pourquoi parce que ben est le
principal produit c'est d'aller au bout
et de gagner le titre suprême de
champion de france et que forcément les
phases finales pour moi je le dis
toujours à chaque fois que jouer les
phases finales avec meyclub
c'est un nouveau championnat qui
commence donc là ils ont fait la
première partie de leurs chefs de la
sédition est allé aux brouzils était
invaincu j'irai pas assez facilement
mais quand même un match de poule oui et
puis sur sur la finale il était un petit
peu accroché c'est normal c'est une
finale
mais ensuite c'est un nouveau choc que
les phases finales ça se passe
complètement différemment
la preuve en est c'est que c'était
c'était le numéro un incontesté du de
l'île de france
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui mais qui a
encore du jus passe de mémoire il ya
vincennes maisons laffitte air-air cpr
c'est quelqu'un qui saute encore en
course donc assez versailles ne peut
avoir que des regrets
déjà parce que perdre perdre en 16e
comme ça aux tirs au but ça laisse des
regrets on verra après le parcours de
vesoul
mais si vous ou là au bout ça laissera
deux fois plus de regrets et que
forcément permanent de la phase finale
ces roms cc c'est le plus dur au rugby
c'est le plus dur au rugby pierre
chevallier vous étiez d'accord avec jean
oui oui parce aussi un souci
perfectionniste
oui quelques regrets pour deux raisons
la première c'est comme l'a rappelé jean
la physionomie du match en lui-même du
seizième de finale contre vesoul de
perdre
aux tirs au but et la deuxième c'est
pour le on va dire le formidable
potentiel que le tableau laisser
laissait envisager et le déroulement
justement de ces phases finales
je pense pas qu'on ait on ait de
meilleures chances d'aller au bout
en honneur ou dans une autre division
que celle ci alors la première raison la
physionomie du match et on peut
considérer même que versait demeure
invaincu parce que à la fin du temps
réglementaire puis des prolongations
considérée comme une des voies les deux
équipes étaient a été a été à égalité
bon évidemment c'est jouer sur les mots
et pillay et parce que au final au final
ces foules qui passe mais c'est
effectivement très rare de termes de
tomber aux tirs au but c'est un scénario
assez stressant parce qu'il faut trouver
5,5 buteur et que ce soit en honneur ou
même dans les autres divisions il n'y a
pas forcément beaucoup de trois-quarts
généralement qu'ils sont qui sont
adroits sur les sur le jeu de pénalité
pour pouvoir passer 5
après si les 5-6 encore égalité c'est la
mort subite donc c'est encore pire
donc voilà sortir sur ce type de
scénario premier intérêt deuxième regret
sur le sur le tableau en lui-même on
voit que et un certain nombre des
favoris qui sont tombés alors versailles
en faisait partie mais il ya aussi le
servette de genève qui était qui était
le gros le gros favori de la poule qui a
été sorti il y en a quelques-uns qui ont
été ont trébuché aussi en 32e de finale
donc il ya monaco notamment qui était
qui était dense est dans cette optique
là donc au fur et à mesure le tableau
s'est un peu éclairci et il ya
effectivement encore trois équipes d'île
de france encore en course ça c'est ce
sont les hasards du tirage au sort et
les scénario assez improbable des
matches de phase finale qui sont des
matches au couteau des matches couperets
qui sont effectivement des matches
totalement totalement inédit et
totalement différent des matches de
poule comme l'a rappelé jean c'est
l'esprit c'est le mental qui prend qui
prend le pas sur le sur le physique donc
oui un deuxième regret c'est justement
7,7
cet alignement des planètes qui nous
permettait peut-être d'imaginer d'aller
le plus loin possible
même si c'était pas dans les objectifs
du début de saison hélène cette défaite
finalement ne remet pas en cause la
saison de versailles selon historique
oui c'est sûr mais ça devait tellement
dur d'arriver justement aux tirs au but
est de constater que finalement c'est
simplement ça qui fait la différence et
je veux pas dire qu'il ya un peu une
part de chance mais il sait 1 c'est
vraiment des petites choses un film qui
font que un club n'a gagné par rapport à
un autre
à cette étape la réconforter en disant
que le champion de france sera
certainement france y lire mais dans ces
cas là c'est encore fait mais peut-être
une possibilité
et est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
mal finalement pour un bien jean cette
défaite
une petite piqûre de rappel pour la
saison prochaine en fédérale 3 non non
non pour moi non parce que ils ont déjà
conscience que la fédérale 3 ce sera pas
aussi facile que que cette saison en
honneur
donc ils n'ont pas besoin de cette
piqûre de rappel et comme on a dit tout
à l'heure ça n'enlève pas la même leur
magnifique saison d'admissibilité
même pierre avec beaucoup d'optimisme a
dit qu'il soit toujours c'est vrai mais
non je pense pas parce que la saison
prochaine ça va remettre devant tout le
monde
tout le monde a rappelé à tout le monde
à 0 ils perdent pas mal de joueurs
pierre l'a dit sur ce plateau et
la dernière émission ils perdent pas mal
de joueurs donc ils ont tout à
reconstruire dans un niveau qui est au
dessus de ski jouer donc je pense que là
cette saison on fait table rase et on
repart sur un autre objectif avec
d'autres d'autres joueurs et surtout y
sera pas la même chose
une départ de réussite aussi de cette
saison on en parle souvent ici c'est la
partie formation ou là on a des jeunes
qui poussent derrière et là encore sur
ceux sur ce 16e sur ce thème du final de
la première et sur le huitième de la
réserve on a quelques juillet en
remontant de cette année qui ont
participé à l'épopée donkey qui engrange
un petit peu d'expérience on a notamment
en réserve et en première non on va dire
surtout en réserve de 2 juniors qui si
quasiment la meilleure performance du
groupe seniors ii sur le huitième de
finale donc on a on a aussi beaucoup
d'optimisme là dessus on a beaucoup
construit justement sur la formation sur
nos sur nos jeunes pour pouvoir les
intégrer au fur et à mesure dans nos
dans nos équipes seniors et l'âge là je
leur tire un grand coup de chapeau ainsi
qu'à tous les staffs qui encadrent nos
jeunes et qui en cas de nos seniors
aussi pour avoir réalisé avec nous avec
nous dirigeants et avec l'ensemble du
club la ville de faire ça une saison il
saison historique en tout cas à l'avenir
s'annonce rayonnant on peut dire pour
aversa les couplets en gros pourvu que
ça dure même si elle même s'il ya
effectivement d'autres c'est un autre
niveau fédéral 3 mai pourvu que ça dure
et pourvu qu'on ait autant d'effectifs
motivé l'année prochaine à ma question
adacore la question est de savoir si une
saison pareille avait quand même pu
déboucher pour le club de versailles sur
je sais pas des nouveaux sponsors ou à
voile a confié ok donc il va y avoir des
moyens mis en place qui va se jouer au
niveau de l'équipe 2 des sponsors et des
joueurs donc c'est quand même une
victoire ils voient qu'il voit de la
lumière le coup de projecteur effet à
juin par rapport à une hausse amour
grâce
à ce plateau est à 7 à cette chaîne
régionale de pouvoir avoir quelqu'un
quelques visibilité aux pulsions tous
ces défis vous suivrez un cas l'année
prochaine en fédérale 3 plaisir ah oui
rapidement non je vous ai tous ces
efforts fournis pour rien
bravo ce sera vous de la fin sur cette
thématique on passe maintenant notre
rubrique focus et on continue dans le
championnat de régionale 3 trappe à
peut-être laissé passer sa chance de
remporter le titre mais l'équipe a fait
un grand pas vers la montée les
trappistes n'ont pu faire mieux que
match nul 1 but partout à l'extérieur
sur le terrain de rueil malmaison
résultat qui leur permet d'être
deuxièmes à une journée de la fin du
championnat le strap conserve trois
points d'avancé sur son adversaire du
jour et un match nul le week-end
prochain pourrait leur offrir la montée
la question sur ce thème les joueurs
doivent-ils gérer ce dernier match
oui ou non voilà on voit là le tableau
justement 38 points pour boulogne
billancourt 36 pour trappe 33 pour rueil
malmaison où voter les joueurs
doivent-ils gérer ce dernier match
oui ou non je réponds pas blanc pour
kamoulox non non je prends contenu la
question est-ce qu'ils doivent gérer oui
nos médias dix matches c'est à dire
voilà faire un trouve nul juste vous
voulez dire des petits bras le petit
bras droit d'inventer
il joue la montée il faut il leur faut
juste un match nul un match nul et s'ils
gagnent on colle d'accord d'accord donc
pour wii dont faisait avec un contrat
houle
moi je pense qu'il faut gérer dans ces
cas là pas dans la manière de jouer mais
plutôt dans ces cas là dans dans la
manière de sélectionner ceux qui vont
jouer c'est pas forcément en
s'économisant sur le terrain qu'on prend
des risques mais c'est parfois en
exposant certains joueurs précieux par
exemple on éviter qu'ils se blessent
donc c'est là que je pense que la
gestion la gestion se met en place et
d'effectivement pas prendre de faire
trop de sacrifices faire trop de
sacrifices tout au long du match mais
jouer quand on joue on joue à fond quoi
qu'il arrive ça mais je rejoins à ce que
ce que dit raul
pour moi il ya un match easy vont
évidemment qu'ils ont pas forcément tout
a donné tout au long du match mais y'a
pas pour moi il n'ya pas d'économie à
avoir sinon c'est pas profité du match
c'est se reposer déjà sur des norias
fins et hommages quoi c'est pas l'esprit
du sport pendant genre moi j'aurais
tendance à dire en football on dit
souvent que la meilleure attaque la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
donc eu par contre l'attack ça
fonctionne pas très bien justement fait
sans souci
ils n'ont marqué que 24 buts en 19
matchs et ben en fait c'est déjà pas mal
qui ont fait l'une des pires attaques du
championnat de la division pirates
attaquent justement donc
si j'ai pas voir mon tacle non mais je
te soit à l'insa lien c'est que l'étrave
14 augie ray par contre trappe et la
meilleure défense du championnat avec
seulement 12 buts encaissés en 19
matches 12 buts encaissés et oui mais en
dix ans jouent alors pour moi je suis
pas fait ça y est du fou de messi joue
la défense pendant 90 minutes ses hauts
risques quand même prendre un je pense
ce qui devra changer leurs façons alors
que j'étais de changer leurs façons si
marche pas s'ils marquent beaucoup de
buts c'est un génial mais au moins ils
ont des bons résultats
je pense qu'il faut qu'ils poussent il
faut qu'ils changent pas leur façon de
faire parce que à vouloir trop gérer
surtout dans le football c'est là où ils
risquent d'avoir des surprises et de
mauvais résultats par une défaite ça
peut les amener malheureusement a pas à
atteindre leurs objectifs
donc pour moi monsieur j'aurais tendance
à dire qu'il faut surtout pas qu'ils qui
joue cool quoi et qu'il faut qu'il joue
comme d'habitude faut pas omettre il
faut maîtriser au niveau tactique à part
joué à dix en défense devant le gardien
il n'y aurait pas d'autre moyen de gérer
le match qui est justement le gérer il
n'y a pas meilleur moyen de se prendre
les pieds dans le tapis à ce moment de
la saison où certes il leur faut qu'un
il leur faut qu'un match nul mais en
l'occurrence il faut il faut provoquer
la chance ont connu des
contre-performances face à des petits
délits qui dit qu'il est plutôt que face
à des grosses équipes il faut il faut
prendre ses responsabilités à une
scénario de match et surtout un surtout
un dénouement ça se provoque
ça se provoque part de la volonté par
deux part de l'ambition collective est
justement gérer le match ne serait qu'un
moyen de se prendre encore une fois les
pieds dans le tapis donc donc il faut
qu'ils jettent toutes leurs forces dans
la bataille plutôt plutôt vous les verts
l'attaquent
on sait jamais sur un match dans la
saison ça peut ça peut s'ouvrir
justement ils peuvent ils peuvent m
ils peuvent mettre des buts il en faut
toujours un de plus que l'adversaire et
même s'il faut un mathieu ça suffit donc
je pense qu'il faut il faut jouer les
lois du sport n'ont pas ce qu'on ne peut
pas se contenter de participer mais
justement d'aller gagner des joncaux
taudis ils jouent contre les mureaux on
a mieux placé mieux table milieu de
tableau en libéro les murs aulas n'a
rien à espérer
aussi la motivation est donc
donc il faut jouer autre chose hélas
parfois là il faut jouer pour l'emporter
si si j'vous pas pour l'emporter il
risque d'avoir une déconvenue une des
comptes donnés ils ont perdu qu'un seul
match ça me soucie c'est à noter ils ont
fait 9 matches nuls on la victoire ils
ont ils ont fait ils n'ont pas bien ce
match voilà donc il faut qu'ils poussent
ils vous aille de l'avant
l'objectif c'est gagner pour et votre
gueule vans ici trébuche
il faut match nul les statistiques
jouent pour a priori aussi à autant de
match nul qui leur faut un actuel ils
vont a priori plutôt pas trop mal
plutôt pas mal il faut une causerie
forte avant le match de la part du coach
je sais pas alors je sais pas comment se
prépare une équipe de foot à man je suis
curieux pour les ongles non je serai
bien que d'assister à une opération
d'une équipe de fait je peux que vous
inviter sur un match ça m'intéresserait
de devoir une préparation d'avant match
d'une équipe de foot ça va assez
différente de celle d'une équipe de
rugby mais
oui il faut certainement oui il faut
leur parler de ça c'est sûr c'est le
rôle c'est un des rôles de l'entraîneur
en tout cas on leur souhaite bon courage
pour ce dernier match de la saison on
espère surtout qu'on ne leur portera pas
la guigne un après ce débat on ouvre une
page sport insolite le jeune thomas
d'eric va tenter un pari fou cette ligne
montant de 20 ans a décidé de traverser
deux déserts en bolivie cet été à pied
en solitaire en totale autonomie et sans
gps la durée du projet devrait durer
environ deux semaines
on écoute le jeune thomas d'eric il
était là présent sur ce plateau sur tv
68 le lundi 20 b parce que j'ai envie de
découvrir de me découvrir dans l'inconnu
d'aller me challenge est à l'autre bout
du monde d'être dans un désert de voir
ce que ça fait quatre milieux de d'une
immensité blanche et d'être tout seul de
ressentir ce que ça fait alors on part
avec un sac à dos de l'eau je pense moi
personnellement j'ai envie de je préfère
prendre de la nourriture lyophilisée ça
diminue le pouvoir c'est pas super bon
mais c'est pratique et après une tente
duvet et voilà une boussole
ça sera suffisant je l'espère
la question sur ce thème validé vous son
esprit aventurier
oui ou non je crois en l'idée de à une
petite misère de la part de raul moi
j'ai une question c'est très partagé
aujourd'hui oreilles vous posez vos
questions à raul j'ai pas eu le temps de
ma forme est sûre le
l'expérience de ce garçon il n'a pas
l'expérience
voilà donc je valide qu'à moitié parce
que vouloir défier la nature je le salue
très bien mais je pense que c'est
intéressant de le faire quand on a un
certain recul une certaine expérience ya
les y aider oui mais l'idée de faire
sachant gps c'est très bien mais je
doute qu'ils ne soient pas suivis tout
au long de sa marche et ça serait
malheureux que au bout du 50ème
kilomètre les secours déjà arrive parce
que ça c'est pas un garçon c'est pas un
athlète entraîné quoi donc s'entraîne un
peu dans la forêt de rambouillet vous
avez tout dit petit peu un petit peu
tendance à il a fait quand même de
nombreuses randonnées en or est d'accord
quand même mais j'ai toujours un c'est
comme quand on fait des traversées de
deux pays dont le climat par déjà
naturel et parfois même social est
hostile
pardon mais j'ai toujours un peu de mal
avec cette cette insouciance semprun
s'en prendre à ma connaissance des
grands risques
voilà je lui souhaite le meilleur mais
voilà je mets une certaine mise en garde
voilà pourquoi je suis mitigé voilà
pourquoi je ne critique pas à 100% parce
que je trouve ça très bien d'aller
explorer des endroits des endroits comme
cela vaste et aride mais bon je mets un
petit rôle à quoi s'était c'était ma
question quelle expérience il a il part
en autonomie ou en semi autonomie
autonomie autonomie totale c'est à dire
oui il n'ya pas de balises sécurité il a
dû suivre ou sol c'est même pas le gps
m'apparaissent limite on peut naviguer
en boussole mais c'est surtout qu'il
faut quand même de l'expérience pour
voilà pour savoir comment traverser
certaines épreuves éviter des blessures
savoir j'espère la nouriture il fait une
petite pause
il repart pour cent kilomètres on part
quand même du désert s'est améliorée aux
traitements naturels
il ya deux jours le double il y aura qu
il va pas pouvoir porter autant d'eau
ils seront pas gratuites n ya pas savoir
faire douter sur le dos la quantité
d'eau qui va lui falloir pour 260 km
s'aggrave après il fait une pause entre
les deux déserts petit oui il a enduré
une oratrice
c'est ça hilarant vers l asie sur le
chemin et c'est surtout que ça dure deux
semaines
enfin je sais pas comment il faut
fouiller je suis une expérience vraiment
en nature dans des conditions extrêmes
avant de la plus grosse traversée se
rassurent le premier désert justement
les 140 km
hormis sur le hormis sur son défi
personnel est ce qu'il ya une autre
raison sur une autre raison sur son son
défi justement global history personnel
voire vous vous rappeliez qui rayent
voudrait également un peu marqué
l'histoire parce qu'il n'ya qu'un homme
qu'il a fait pour l'instant un français
et il avait 50 ans donc il fallait
plusieurs personnes qui l'ont fait mais
jamais aussi jeune a 20 ans c'est la
preuve en est c'est qu'on en parle sur
sur ce plateau là on parle de tous les
jours ici donc donc c'est un bon signe
déjà pour lui vouera poli qui s'entraîne
en forêt de rambouillet moi je trouve
que c'est préparer la traversée de la
manche à la nage dans une piscine c'est
donc s'élancer de la première réserve
après j'espère que qu'il a les
ressources mentales et il a envie
d'aller au bout de ce défi mais il n'a
pas choisi plus facile ça c'est clair
les déserts d'amérique du sud sont pas
réputés comme étant les plus les plus
accueillants chaud d'afrique non plus
d'ailleurs mais en notre justice a remis
lui des complications dans le désert
c'est un désert de sel en gtc l'extrême
sécheresse il y à théo sibilité pour qui
saigne régulièrement du nez notamment à
cause de l'irritation provoquée par le
fait avec des cristaux de sel et autres
d'okola donc à part à 50 à partir de 30
minutes on peut commencer à saigner du
nez moi ce que je suis ce qui m'inquiète
c'est vraiment le n'a pas l'air d'avoir
eu aucune expérience en milieu hostile
en milieu naturel
un peu intense est passé de la forêt de
rambouillet après l étude et son
parcours où il est passé il faut déjà
regarder ressenti la fatigue saônates
fondée mais j'ai pensé à ces gens qui se
font un kiki qui vont aller
photographier les lions de trop près
paix qui se finissent par se faire
mordre
c'est la nature
je ne sais pas s'il imagine injustement
les règles les répercussions à quel
point ça peut être difficile challenge
repos sans préparation avec des
spécialistes qui sont habitués à faire
des passes kassaraté très que ça va pas
l'être parce que je sais pas ce que je
hurle à nivelles j'imagine qu'il va être
ultra surveillé mais ce qu'ils veulent
mais bon ça va
quel crédit on va lui accorder six jeudi
les secours arrivent au bout du 50ème
kilomètre
c'est ça que il va pas mourir c'est le
succès qui n'a pas déjà qu il n'ya pas
de balises
il va partir tout seul ouais il sera
sheryfa moi c'est ce que je sais que je
pourrai ils vont pas faire plus haut
niveau plancher comme ça dans des
jacqueries déjà pu voir une campagne ces
dernières semaines son propre aveu
d'accord glissait-il personnel
moi ça fait ça c'est d'accord c'est bien
qu'on me disait raul wayne et on lui
accorde un crédit parce que c'est bien
la veine cela s'il veut les démarches
s'offrir aussi sauf que quand même sauf
que quand même assez le profit s'il
marche pas bien
la franchise et rigueur sont foireux
chercher enfin le secourir
voilà 7 km h au cap à l'entraînement
s'est pas cependant dans les bacs à
sable au château de joux à vos beaux
draps mouillés là à faire traverser le
bac à sable qui va arriver
il ya 0-0 prise de conscience du danger
qui peut qui peut rencontrer face à face
à ce nom mais j'en ai fait moi aussi je
suis fut c'est bien pour eux pour pour
pour l'initiative c'est bien mais après
après après c'est passablement calculé
en disant voilà je vais passer il a tiré
un fil pour les fixer alors ça va moins
d'août c'est là où il aura beau tom
qu'est ce que je veux dire il a décidé
du jour il a décidé de faire ce projet
depuis quand depuis quelques années je
l'avais ça oui donc en niveau de temps
de préparation même de temps de
préparation mentale dans sa tête mais il
a vraiment concrétisé un style de la
famille de bellion avec les lions la
navy à des fusions au navigateur il est
bon dans sa famille ne mange pas par un
gpu dafoe latine à lanton cette
commission est rare chez un peu proche
dans les discours plus doux rêveur ouais
ils ont l'air un petit peu peut-être
qu'ils auraient une rencontre entre les
deux un jour ben pourquoi pas aussi
pourquoi pas on va le suivre on te tiens
voilà en l'encourageant sur ce plateau
et on va le suivre
on va surtout débriefer quand ils ont à
réaliser ce défi
on passe maintenant notre page débats
[Musique]
dans notre page débat aujourd'hui on a
parlé de golf ce mardi 21 mai une
cinquantaine de sportifs de haut niveau
au niveau se sont réunis autour d'une
partie de golf ont participé au tiebreak
une compétition amicale qui fêtait cette
année sa 27e édition dans les yvelines
en parallèle à ces sportifs ont animé
des ateliers avec des jeunes venus de
cinq établissements y vinoy la
celle-saint-cloud elancourt trappe
versailles et maurepas on écoute la
fondatrice et organisatrice de
l'événement véronique chaplin ils ont
fait de la boxe avec trois champions du
monde ils étaient ils ont fait de
l'athlétisme du football avec trois
stars du psg et on tournait sur six
ateliers donc une journée ensoleillée
extraordinaire
la soirée s'est terminée par une vente
aux enchères à but caritatif
on pouvait notamment retrouver la
raquette de novak djokovic ou des
maillots signés par les joueurs du paris
saint germain
on voit justement les lots l'année la
raquette de novak djokovic qui a été
adjugé à plus de 3000 euros
verra-t-il le maillot de ferhati alors
voilà ce que vous vous connaissez pierre
chevalier du coup cette cette opération
qu'est ce que vous en pensez que je
connais très bien cette opération qui
est une opération qui mérite d'être
d'être salué parce que c'est un pic et
le sport dans des dans des démarches
sociales dans démarche caritative et
s'est impliqué sur tous les sportifs de
haut niveau au haut niveau du sport
amateur et en l'occurrence une belle
compétition de golf le matin
l'après-midi des olympiades avec
justement ces jeunes qui viennent qui
viennent essayer différents sports et
surtout de voter voilà confrontés en
face de sportifs qu'ils idolâtrent
peut-être par ailleurs donc c'est c'est
une fantastique occasion pour eux deux
d'être au plus près de ses champions là
qui le temps d'un le temps d'une journée
justement donnent un peu de leur temps
donnent un peu de leur énergie pour pour
justement leur donner un petit peu de un
petit peu de soleil aussi un petit peu
de de sport et de challenge dans l'eure
dans leur quotidien donc c'est un c'est
un événement où tous les sports font
très bon ménage avec justement cette
approche sociale cette approche amicale
conviviale et c'est vraiment des
journées assez unique que ce soit par le
tennis ou par le golf c'est là où
véronique les organisent c'est vraiment
de deux belles journées et qui après
rayonne en plus vont au delà de nos
frontières avec des actions qui sont
menées par les gazelles au maroc ou en
afrique donc c'est vraiment de belles
actions qu'il faut saluer et le tiebreak
roland garros n'est pas le seul
événement de ce type dans les yvelines
il y avait également le trophée sport
passion organisée par régine gandolfini
c'est le même concept des golfeurs
jouent sur le green et font la promotion
d'une association sélectionnés par le
département des yvelines
moi justement les images qui ont été
tournées la semaine dernière la question
sur ce thème on valide ses projets je
pose la question quand même
raul ça vous fait
ouais ça me plaît énormément et c'est
d'ailleurs c'est ça fait ressortir
l'aspect du sport qui me plaît le plus
je suis très admirative de tous ces gens
qui organisent ce genre d'événements non
pas et c'est le don par le sport c'est
pas pratiquer le sport pour soi et pour
progresser mais dans un dans un souci de
le transmettre et de s'en servir pour
l'ouvrir avraiment le démocratiser au
maximum et et s'en servir pour avoir
apporté quelque chose socialement et je
trouve ça même touchant moi je de donner
l'occasion à des jeunes comme ça de de
rencontrer leurs idoles de de se réunir
autour des belles valeurs que sont le
sport est encore d'avoir l'intelligence
de de générer des fonds par cette vente
aux enchères je trouve que c'est un
vraiment de a à z un projet magnifique
et très émouvant et il en faut de plus
en plus soit là et ça permet aussi
encore de nouveau là la proximité entre
l'élite et le sport pratiqué en à
l'échelle du loisir donc tout ce que
j'aime vraiment tout ce que j'aime
hélène est ce que ça leur apporte
vraiment ses enfants oui je pense que ça
apporte aussi des choses aux sportifs
qui viennent parce que c'est renouer
avec un petit peu l'esprit
peut-être qu'ils avaient au début avant
d'avoir une carrière et ses terrasses et
se mettre à leur portée
c'est aussi une partie intégrante du
sport est pareil ça fait des souvenirs
ça fait ça crée des vocations yade et
voilà il ya des bonnes causes ça porte à
tout le monde en fait genre vous avez
laissé un objet pour la vente aux
enchères city break je peux pas dire
jusqu'au palais je peux pas le divulguer
à cette émission
pierre ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
c'est que ces deux événements existe
quasiment depuis une trentaine d'années
et la ferme cran grand coup de chapeau à
2 2 deux grandes dames du sport et de
l'événement en ile-de-france et en
france vers aux chapelains pour le
tiebreak et régine camp nou le fini pour
le trophée sport passion elles sont
toutes les deux très impliqués dont
justement le rayonnement du sport et des
sportifs
et puis et puis justement de cette
dimension sociale et cette dimension
festive événement sienne qui permet
justement de faire rayonner rayonner les
bons esprits et les bonnes valeurs sur
tous les terrains de sport et notamment
sur deux parcours de golf en
l'occurrence mais aussi sur les sur les
rings et et les panneaux de les paniers
de basket aussi pour le pour le tiebreak
donc c'est un grand coup de chapeau pour
ces deux grandes dames justement sur les
greens
il ya quand même une petite compétition
amicale certes mais les sportifs ont en
tout cas envie de revenir sur les greens
pour perfectionner leur swing on écoute
yannick noah et philippe candeloro au
micro de tv 78
c'est comme si le cnosf voiliers avaient
organisé un grand événement entre
sportifs d'hiver et sportive d'été voilà
on est en espèces d'intersaison entre le
début de la saison pour les sportifs des
jeux d'été et puis ceux qui viennent de
finir la saison d'hiver donc je trouve
que c'est bien d'avoir ce rassemblement
parce qu'on l'a de moins en moins et
puis alors surtout quand on est un
ancien athlète de haut niveau on l'a
plus du tout tant que finalement c'est
bien de revoir des collègues c'est super
la nature avec des potes ils sont
coriaces mais pas sympa c'est cool c'est
une belle ça c'est une belle journée
c'est une belle journée soirée en
général ça se termine c'est un genre de
réactions côté festif vrai on a ça dit
gamme avec le discours de yannick noah
que voilà que c'était un très cool et et
que la soirée gamme ça finissait bien a
dit de feu voilà parabole
en tout cas c'est vrai que ça fait
plaisir de voir les sportifs s'amuse
également mais ça permet aussi de
justement de les voir sous un autre
aspect que toujours dans l'aspect
réussite d'un challenge sportif mais
dans une ambiance de décontraction
surtout qu'ils sont pas tous leur sport
bien sûr et donc voilà s'en détacher un
petit peu mais le goal justement il est
un très bon score pour les anciens ils
font des anciens sportifs et les actuels
d'ailleurs aussi mais c'est justement
une un côté convivial et
et sportif est mal et malgré tout
compétitifs parce qu'on se rend compte
que les sportifs quels que soient leur
leur sport candeloro leur en parle et
les anciens sportifs de haut niveau se
mettent au golf et se met avec la même
hargne
on a parlé aussi avec ian il ya du
verrier sur certaines de ses émissions
ici sur ce plateau commencé le golf
aussi c'est c'est mettre le doigt dans
un engrenage vertueux justement qui mêle
compétition mentale balade balade dans
la nature et de gros gros moment de
convivialité donc là elle n'a ils le
vivent
justement en dehors de leur sport mais
avec avec je pense une un vrai esprit
festif et convivial
ça sera le mot de la fin sur cette
thématique on passe maintenant notre
page découverte
[Musique]
un rendez vous qu'il nous faudra
absolument pas manquer ce samedi 25 mai
à l'open de canne de combat est
organisée donc ce samedi à partir de 14h
à viroflay au centre sportif gaillon un
sport très populaire au 19ème siècle qui
est revenue au goût du jour ces
dernières années présentation de ce
sport par un moniteur julien mode là
donc c'est un bout de bois de 95
centimètres en châtaignier la canne de
combat en fait c'est une sorte d scream
avec son histoire ses traditions et sa
propre codification à la différence de
l'escrim manière classique on va ni
tranché ni piqué on va respecter un
principe d'efficacité qui veut que tous
les coups soit armé et exécutée avec le
maximum d'amplitude donc ça donne un
côté naturellement esthétique et très
ample c'est ce qu'on va rechercher
enveloppe la question sur ce thème
est-ce qu'il faut rien tu retires la
canne de combat
attention je suis mitigé bon avec
modération avec remettre au goût du jour
à remettre au goût du jour
parce que c'était une discipline qui
avait disparu qui ré mairie parce que
c'est c'est un ensemble de valade de de
sport sa faim ça prend quelques petites
donc oui il faut réintroduire la canne
de combat
voilà ça c'est codifié d'une façon en
prenant un petit peu d informations ont
pris deux arrêtés parmi d'autres sports
etc
et je pense qu'il ya vraiment des
faudrait voir des vraiment des matches
ou des choses à faire avec je ne sais
pas pour vous mais moi j'aime bien ce
genre oui moi je suis si je suis je suis
c'est la fin des missions c'est la fin
de l'émission kontant mais avec aucune
15 95 cm fondation peut faire mal donc
oui il avait deux prix 2 j'avais deux
bon il ya 95 à diverses affaires
d'argent a peur c'est la première fois
que va t on faire attention à la
tentation 95 ça voilà mais sinon oui moi
je suis pour
pour leur introduction d de la can a
surtout mais avec modération si mal de
khanabad avis en plus donc moi je dis
oui parce que c'est on voit quand
certains sports qui veulent émerger
c'est à d'ici là j'ai pu les tester un
genre ouais là je là je suis l'univers
harry potter je veux prépare justement
je me prépare pour le quidditch je fais
pas comme notre ami qui va traverser
domaine le désert un centre dans des
bacs à sable
moi je me prépare pour le coup dit
d'ailleurs je préférais ou quidditch
avec la canne à 95 a dit m et vous allez
voir un peu ce que je vais faire moi je
suis pauvre on a hâte en tout cas pierre
chevalier ça fait partie de ces a priori
sports ancestraux qui qui mêle pas mal
de pas mal de sport qu'on connaît les
scream peut-être la savate
il était aussi des coups on a vu aussi
il y avait ajourné de kent homes cadeau
pour la partie asiatique d'ailleurs été
rattachée à la fédération française de
boxe française
il a exprimé ce crime ce qu'ils sont
maîtres d'armes aussi donc c'est de
toute façon a salué les acquis qui le
premier a sorti ce sport là des cartons
ou des vieilles caisses de l'histoire ça
semble déjà aussi à recueillir un
certain accueilli un certain public et
mg ml un certain nombre de choses là on
peut parler de sport parce qu'il est
vraiment une préparation signée du
physique et du mental
il ya de la drees donc c c'est de toute
façon a salué dans la mesure où c'est il
ya un certain nombre la classe
spectaculaire pour le coup pour le coup
ça vaut le coup de je pense à y voir un
sport en tout cas été présentés lors de
l'exposition universelle de 1900 et
comme sport de démonstration aux jeux
olympiques d'été en 1924
donc c'est un sport qui était très
populaire dans cette es là c'était
surtout pour se défendre en fait y avait
une canne voilà les gens avaient des cas
dans la rue il se défend menée contre
les voyous dans les rues de paris
mais le problème c'est que après mais
voyons quand la ccan la sécurité est
arrivée à paris il notamment le port de
l'épée quand il n'y a plus besoin
d'armes cormary il ya une jeune n'diaye
publié avec le besoin de ça et du coup
ça s'est perdu sur l'histoire de nos
chaînes avec une canne de combat c'est
du briol du tigre c'est un sport complet
et est éventuellement pour moi qui
traite aujourd'hui je vais vous dire je
suis même un petit peu jalouse pour les
générations à venir parce que moi enfant
j'avais une obsession pour les combats
d'épées tous les films dp gladiateurs
tous âges avaient vraiment c'était une
obsession mais je n'étais pas du tout
pistolet tout ça avec combats à l'épée
les chevaliers tous à 12 mai et du coup
c'est vrai que moi j'ai fait beaucoup
des scream
mais la pratique de l'escrimé je me
retrouvais pas vraiment parce que
c'était quand même une discipline très
c'était de l'escrim ce n'est pas du
combat à l'épée ce que la part ça ça par
endroits dans les films
designs à six attaques donc si le flanc
la tête et les jambes
à l'époque ce sport vraiment répondu à
ma demande est mort ça m'aurait évité
d'aller taper tout le monde avec mon
épée à l'époque qui voudraient serait
allé à la salle de cana canne de combat
voit la balle il est pas trop tard mais
bon voilà j'ai d'autres occupations va
nous enchaînons 7
cette résurgence s'est pas vraiment
parce que c'est depuis les années 50
encore que ça a été réintroduit du coup
on est dans la com sport mais c'est
vraiment depuis que depuis une vingtaine
d'années qu'il y a vraiment des
licenciés 4002 entre 4000 et dix mille
licenciés mais ça m'étonnerait pas que
s'aggraver mais tout aussi petit tu
rêvais de reprendre la can
non moi je mentais la marque déjà
responsables comment commencer la pole
dance utilisé peut-être que la can après
la diya prix plus gros pour faire le
tour
mais c'est ça c'est pourquoi nous
sanctionner pour ce petit dérapage année
j'ai fait la blague avant
est ce que vous pourriez en tout cas
vous testez wacken
j'ai vu quand même chose ils sont quand
même assez
s'ils se déplacent de chance à la ken
well thème de combat que moi maman avec
la grâce d'allah avec la grande vedette
mais mais moi j'attends c'est
spectaculaire
en tout cas c'est ce samedi 25 mai avis
europe et c'est super esthétique connaît
beaucoup d'élégance je peux pas je
m'entraîne à la traversée et mocassins
tient qu'aux témoins
que les gammes des classes greenway que
vrai équipements avec une vraie tenue
soit développé son puisse se donner à
fond il faudrait qu'on soit plus protégé
peut-être quand il y aura plus de lits
sont exactement parce que tu exprimes on
fait d'abord une tenue
c'est la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui focus sur une
citation du basketteur michael jordan
située à bord donne une fois cela peut
devenir une habitude n'abandonne jamais
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 68
[Musique]